hey guys Pete here today we're going to
talk about that long sequence at the
beginning of episode 3 or in twin peak
season 3 if you haven't watched that yet
then you're going to want to stop
watching this video because it will
certainly spoil it so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to break down the scene
and if you want to skip that check the
description because there will be a
timestamp link that will take you
straight to where we talked about the
theories and general impressions of what
it all means so let's talk about part
threes opening sequence we catch up with
Cooper as he's still falling through
space after a short detour through the
glass box in New York City he drops into
what appears to be an otherworldly
environment before we see him touchdown
or what I guess you would call a balcony
we see a cloud of light purple smoke it
sort of spreads out and we also see what
looks to be an endless ocean that has a
purple tint to it as well
I read a post on reddit where someone
said that this whole thing sort of looks
like a slot machine tray but I didn't
really read much into that anyways agent
Cooper take two look around before going
through a window inside the building in
there has a much different visual feel
outside things were desolate but
basically calm and inside this room
things are fuzzy and distorted coop
encounters a woman inside who is blind
or a woman who doesn't have eyes
depending on how you interpret it it's
not exactly clear what is going on with
her but there is a smooth looking skin
covering her eye sockets with a few
areas that could be like scar tissue the
room itself almost resembles a bunker it
has a hot it has high ceilings a sitting
area and a fireplace in front of where
they sit the characters move forward and
backwards making things jerky with the
occasional looping of movements and
gestures as coupe approaches the woman
he asks her where is this where are we
and it's interesting that Cooper seems
to be his normal self here and this is
really the last time we see him in that
state the woman never speaks or he
doesn't communicate
with words she inspects Cooper with her
hands and makes indiscernible noises but
primarily interact by doing gestures as
they sit we hear a clanking clanging
pounding noise which we perceive as
knocking on a door from outside she
warns coop to keep quiet while this is
going on while the knocking continues
Cooper notices what ends up being the
most important part of the room a panel
on the wall that looks electrical or
machine like with a circle at its center
with the number 15 above it
he seems drawn to it and gets up to
approach it when he gets close it
affects him almost like a bug zapper
and the woman rushes over the woman
rushes over and positions herself in
between coop and the panel and she is
visibly concerned and seems emphatic
about him not getting any closer
she makes what looks like flashing
movements to drive home her point so
this is a really intense part with all
that's going on the looping effect on
her motions the slashing sound along
with the music and the persistent
clanging or pounding make this section
one of the coolest things I've seen on
TV for quite a while she makes her way
to the opposite wall and waves after
coop to follow they go through a small
door a regular-sized door I guess and
she starts to ascend up a ladder at the
top they exit through a hatch out there
it appears that everything we've seen so
far is contained inside a black metal
box which is floating in deep space for
lack of any better description on top of
the box there is what looks like a
thimble shaped object with a few gauges
and a switch on it she tries to
communicate something to Cooper who just
sort of stand there looking thoroughly
confused she moves herself around and
flips the switch peers to have
electricity flowing through her and then
it basically ejected from the box
falling through space pounding sound
stops at this point and then supersedes
the disembodied head of major bricks
blows by and he says two words which are
blue rose
a Cooper after that coupe takes one last
look around and head back down the
ladder when he re-enters the room we see
his movements are fluid again and that
the blurry effect is gone we also see
that the electrical panel on the wall
has changed and now instead of the
number 15 it reads number 3 above the
what we pretty much figure out is an
electrical outlet later there's a
different woman sitting on the couch at
this point this time she has eyes can
communicate with words and is played by
the actress who played ronette Pulaski
in the original run but a little bit
more about that later it's impossible to
tell if cooper recognizes her since he
is recognizing that everything is
different at the very same time he comes
back into this room as he approaches she
checks her watch and we see that it's
252 which brings to mind what the arm
had said earlier two five three time and
time again here we get a glimpse outside
of the real world we find out that evil
coupe is still driving down that highway
in South Dakota and getting a shot of
his dashboard clock we see that it's
also you know it's all happening at the
same time his clock is at 252 as well
run net not run that speaks to Cooper as
he approaches the panel and says when
you get there you will already be there
Cooper moves towards the panel and gets
that and we see evil coupe in his car
and it looks like he feels it as well we
also see again that evil coupe has a
cigarette lighter open and make the
assumption that electricity is important
to what's going on the knocking comes
back and ronette not run that tells
Cooper that he'd better hurry because
her mother's coming Cooper then allows
himself to be pulled into the panel
which turns out to be a portal and the
portal that looks to be an electrical
outlet like I said before while this is
happening evil coupe loses control as a
car completely and crashes on the side
of the road later we see that normal
coupe materializes through an electrical
socket where Dougy had just disappeared
to take his place and that is where the
strange sequence comes to
and so there's a lot to talk about here
if you skip the breakdown welcome to the
video going we're going to discuss my
initial thoughts and go over the most
interesting theories that I've seen in
the past few days since I've already
made separate videos about the glass box
and about dougie I'll try to stay on the
topic of this opening sequence and you
can go watch those ones later if you
haven't seen them already my initial
thought after realizing dougie was a
decoy to prevent evil coupe from being
returned to the lodge was pretty simple
it was that this room that is a
transitional space where his plan played
out in other words when coop first
enters everything seems dark and scary
and somewhat like what he might guess
evil coups head would be inside if we
could see in there after NATO the the
first woman we see literally flips a
switch things seem much more calm and
Dougie light the numbers changing on the
panel could be an indication that if
coop had passed through straightaway and
never followed NATO he would have
switched with evil coop and returned
things back to normal so yeah this is
simple and fits within what we know
happened but also leaves a lot of stuff
out things like dougie wearing the ring
the two women in the room and the
pounding noise coming from ronette not
Ronettes
mother I say Ron might not run that
because she's not credited as ronette
Pulaski in the end of the episode she's
credited as American girl other people
have brought up in the comments of my
other videos that may be the first woman
is supposed to be Josie and the second
is supposed to be
ronette but I really don't see anything
that ties all those things together I'm
not saying it's not important that they
you know David Lynch picked this actress
to play this part I'm just saying we
don't know enough to understand if it's
just because coop is imagining these
people in a certain way or that because
Ron that had some connection with large
stuff that you know that could be part
of it I really don't think we know
enough to say why that's important just
yet so yeah the simple idea here is
you know it's all just part of evil
coups plan and those two women important
or not are there to make sure everything
goes according to how he wants it to of
course it's not very Twin Peaks ee to go
with a simple answer so there are plenty
of other ideas out there to consider the
first thing that caught my attention was
the actual name or what we call this
place it seemed at first most of the
stuff I was reading online was referring
to it as the Machine room because the
electrical panel looked quite like a
machine after that I started seeing the
term the mod zone and you know modders
Allah is a light shade of purple which
we see at the beginning and this name
also has a really nice ring to it
but the redditor who started using that
name further explained it and I'll go
into that
ketchum 26 who is active in the Twin
Peaks subreddit wrote that the term mod
zone is taken from the writing of
Kenneth Grahame apparently grant was the
first person to associate Western
occultism and magic with a k' with alien
abduction phenomenon he was also the
first to really emphasize the role of
Jack Parsons in the history of cultism
mark frost uses both of those ideas in
the secret history of Twin Peaks so
Ketchum 26 concludes that he must have
read grants writings and grant believe
that magical manipulation of reality
could be done with the help of alien
beings in the Mausam which is basically
a self-contained world at the very edge
of reality between what we can
experience and what can only you know
what we can only conceive of as
non-existence
now the param non-existence is to throw
back to what the arms doppelganger says
before cute departs the Red Room and you
know if you haven't read the secret
history there is quite a bit about this
Jack Parsons character and you know a
lot of it seems to match up with where
things might go especially with the
major breaks connection and the
oh stop since I've never actually read
any of grants writing I'm not really
sure if alien beings here are specific
to beings from other planets or if they
could be just non-human beings because
honestly at the end of the secret
history one of the things that came to
mind was that even though they talked
about aliens a lot it wasn't necessarily
in a way to say that aliens from other
planets were real but that something was
behind all of this phenomena related to
what we think of as UFOs and alien
abductions and so on now that's a whole
other video that I'm going to do with
the secret history so I'll just be away
from that and say that the mob zone is a
catchy name for it it's my favorite name
for it and it's an interesting take on
where the idea for this sequence might
have come from another theory out there
has to do with the different types of
electricity
you might remember learning about Thomas
Edison electrocuting a full-grown
elephant when he was competing with
Nikolai or Nikola Tesla well there are
two types of electricity and that's what
that whole thing was about alternating
current or AC and direct current or DC
redditor seriously not cool wrote that
the switch NATO flips on top of the box
changed the panel on the wall from AC to
DC he points out that the room is no
longer going back and forth in time
that's in relation to alternating
current it basically moves back and
forth to keep things really simple and
that the building is then all set in DC
mode his idea is that NATO did that in
order to help coop enter the car where
evil coupe is and then he isn't near a
wall socket which transmits AC but near
a car lighter which is DC this of course
would all be coordinated by Mike in the
arm but it doesn't end up working
because they don't know about dougie and
so on and so forth overall I'm not sure
I feel about this idea since one there
was no electricity to speak of back in
the times of twisted hair in Lewis and
Clark and also why wouldn't evil coop
just go somewhere far away from any
electrical devices at 2:53 and weighed
it out it's an interesting idea all the
electricity stuff but it doesn't quite
add up for me let me know what you guys
think about that the most recent
development in mob zone Theory crafting
I guess you would call it is a video
well redditor our creme posted today a
video that shows the scenes with the
glass box and the mob zone overlapped
this is definitely somewhat interesting
but I think that everyone should keep in
mind that the nonlinear presentation
would sort of line these scenes up
anyways I'm not saying you know Lynch
did it on purpose or didn't do it but I
do know that he wrote this out so that
these things are all happening at the
same time so there would be a little bit
of overlap just keep that in mind
basically the idea here is that Lynch
shot three separate scenes in three
different parts of the return that were
set up to be synchronized and work
together in the YouTube video we see a
split screen and timestamp of the glass
box Massacre from part one first we see
how coop moves through the box while Sam
and Tracy are out of the you know room
at the hall and we already saw that sort
of thanks to the way part two was edited
Lynch gives us a hint that those things
are when those things are happening then
depending on your level of skepticism we
see the mob zone team and it appears to
match up with Sam and Tracy's murder the
most interesting things here include
NATO making her slashing motions while
Sam and Tracy are well getting slashed
the pounding town starting in the mob
zone when Tracy climbs on top of Sam
after they both get naked and the lamp
lighting up in the zone when Sam starts
to notice that something's going on in
the box like basically this plant flicks
on in the background and at the very
same time we sort of see that the box is
filling up with the black smoke at the
end of the day I'm not sure how much
more of the mystery this explains but
it's definitely interesting to watch
these scenes sync up whether it was
intentional or not so what does it all
mean hell if I know let me know what you
guys think in the comments one thing I
do know for sure is that
like to create mystery and that gives us
a lot to speculate about I mean we have
still been trying to figure out what's
going on in the Red Room and room above
the convenience store for 20-some odd
years since that stuff was first
introduced so do I think there's a clear
map here and in the scene that tells us
what we want to know probably not it's
mystery building it's mystery for the
sake of mystery but there are a lot of
interesting things and I do love to
speculate so please subscribe to my
channel like the video if you found it
enjoyable and check back soon because
more Twin Peaks videos are coming thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon